This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. Over the past several years, I've explored hundreds of ideas on Hidden Brain on how we can live better lives and have healthier relationships. Many of these ideas have felt provocative and insightful to me. And as I interview guests and edit stories, I tell myself, I'm going to remember to apply these ideas to my own life. I'll follow the advice of researchers who've discovered how we can have better relationships. I'll become a better colleague, parent, and citizen.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。在过去的几年里，我在《隐藏的大脑》中探讨了数百个关于我们如何过上更好的生活、建立更健康关系的观点。其中许多观点让我感到发人深省且富有洞察力。在采访嘉宾和编辑故事时，我告诉自己，我一定要记住将这些想法应用到我自己的生活中。我会遵循那些研究人员的建议，他们发现了我们如何才能拥有更好的关系。我会成为更好的同事、父母和公民。
But in my daily life, I forget to apply these lessons all the time. I'm impatient when I should be patient. I'm distracted when I should be focused. And I'm harsh with myself when I should be patient, I'm distracted when I should be focused, and I'm harsh with myself when I should be kind." Psychologists sometimes call this the insight action gap. Knowing the right thing to do doesn't automatically mean we do the right thing. It isn't about hypocrisy per se, it's that learning something and doing something involve different sets of brain muscles, so to speak. This is a very ancient idea and something that many religious and spiritual traditions have explored over
但在日常生活中，我总是忘记应用这些经验教训。我本该耐心时却变得急躁。我本该专注时却心不在焉。我本该善待自己时却对自己苛刻。心理学家有时称之为“洞察力与行动之间的鸿沟”。知道正确的事情并不自动意味着我们就会去做正确的事情。这本身并不是虚伪，而是因为学习某事和做某事涉及不同的脑部肌肉，可以这么说。这是一个非常古老的观点，也是许多宗教和精神传统在过去几个世纪中探索过的主题。
the centuries. It's an old idea in art and literature too. In the 16th century, William Shakespeare wrote, I can easier teach 20 what were good to be done, than be one of the 20 to follow my own teaching. Today on the show, we explore the inside action gap when it comes to our debates with our political opponents. It's the third episode in our series, Us 2.0, where we explore how we can become more effective talking across our differences. If you've missed any of the other episodes in this series, please
这在艺术和文学中也是一个古老的观点。16世纪，威廉·莎士比亚写道：“教导二十个人什么是该做的，比做那二十个人中的一员去践行自己的教导要容易得多。”今天在节目中，我们将探讨在与政治对手辩论时出现的“洞察力与行动之间的鸿沟”。这是我们系列节目《我们2.0》的第三集，探讨我们如何能更有效地跨越分歧进行对话。如果你错过了本系列的其他剧集，请
be sure to check them out in this podcast feed. Why reason and empathy desert us when we need them most and how to close the inside action gap? This week on Hidden Brain. As we look at the news, it's hard not to feel like the world is constantly in flames. New conflicts, pile on top of old conflicts, and antagonisms and disagreements seem to erupt everywhere. Conflicts also abound in our personal and professional lives. How should we handle them? How can we learn to diffuse them?
务必在我们的播客订阅源中查看。为什么理性和同理心在我们最需要它们时离我们而去？以及如何弥合“洞察力与行动之间的鸿沟”？本周的《隐藏的大脑》。当我们审视新闻时，很难不觉得世界仿佛正处于水深火热之中。新的冲突叠加在旧的冲突之上，敌意和分歧似乎在各地爆发。我们的个人生活和职业生活中也充满了冲突。我们应该如何处理它们？我们如何学会化解它们？
At Columbia University, psychologist Peter Coleman studies how minor disagreements turn into endless conflicts, and how our own thought patterns can deepen divides or help us to mend fences. Peter Coleman, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Peter, in 2019 you were invited to attend a conference in Germany. It looked at the emerging challenges in the Middle East and ideas to bring about peace. Now, I understand the whole conference itself was focused on the idea of bringing together
在哥伦比亚大学，心理学家彼得·科尔曼研究微小的分歧是如何演变成无休止的冲突的，以及我们自己的思维模式如何加深分歧或帮助我们修复关系。彼得·科尔曼，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你的邀请。彼得，2019年你受邀参加了在德国举行的一次会议。会议审视了中东地区新出现的挑战以及实现和平的构想。据我了解，整个会议本身就聚焦于将
these very seasoned negotiators and diplomats. The idea was that by putting all these experienced heads together, you would come up with initiatives that could be applied in the real world. Yeah. It was a very impressive group of contributors. It was chaired by a senior person in the field who'd spent most of his life studying international conflict, international peace processes, and he had assembled quite an impressive group of mostly, you know, former envoys or former ambassadors and then academics like myself
这些经验丰富的谈判代表和外交官聚集在一起。其理念是，通过汇集这些经验丰富的头脑，你们可以提出能够在现实世界中应用的倡议。是的。这是一个非常令人印象深刻的贡献者群体。会议由该领域的一位资深人士主持，他一生大部分时间都在研究国际冲突和国际和平进程，他召集了一群非常令人印象深刻的人，主要是前特使或前大使，以及像我这样的学者
or people from think tanks. And the idea was, yes, to offer current insights into what to do about the Middle East conflict. In particular, it was really about what can we do to make a difference in this sort of new era of more complex conflicts. So the conference took a turn in one of the final sessions. Paint me a picture of what happened. So this was a presentation by one of the co-chairs. He was in Israeli and he presented a paper, a kind of conceptual model of complex systems and conflict.
或来自智库的人。其理念确实是为如何处理中东冲突提供当前的见解。特别是，它真正关注的是，在这个充满更复杂冲突的新时代，我们能做些什么来有所作为。所以会议在最后几场会议之一中发生了转折。请为我描述一下发生了什么。这是一位联合主席的演讲。他是一位以色列人，他发表了一篇论文，一种关于复杂系统和冲突的概念模型。
His responded happened to be a former ambassador, a former Dutch ambassador who also was a contributor to this. And he said something like, given the fact that you're an Israeli and the book is focused on Israel and Palestine, my guesses will get more scrutiny than usual. And that's about as far as he got in his comments. And at that point, my Israeli colleague stopped and said something like, what are you saying? And the Dutch ambassador, you know, paused for a second and looked at me and said, well,
他的回应者恰好是一位前大使，一位也参与了此次会议的前荷兰大使。他说了一些类似这样的话：“鉴于你是一名以色列人，而这本书关注的是以色列和巴勒斯坦，我猜它会受到比平时更多的审查。”他的评论也就到此为止了。就在那时，我的以色列同事停下来，说了一些类似“你这话是什么意思？”的话。而那位荷兰大使停顿了一秒钟，看着我说：“嗯，
what I was trying to say is, you know, given that this is about Israel and you're in Israeli, and the Israeli colleague then came back and said, yes, but what exactly are you saying? And he clearly was upset and triggered and it got tense from there. And of course, we're a room full of peace makers, peace builders or scientists that study that. And at some point, the other chair, the senior member of the group, tried to put a stop to it and said something like, all right, enough of this foolishness.
我试图说的是，鉴于这与以色列有关，而你又是一名以色列人……”然后那位以色列同事反驳道：“是的，但你到底想说什么？”他显然很不安，被触动了，气氛从那时起变得紧张起来。当然，我们满屋子都是和平缔造者、和平建设者或研究这些问题的科学家。在某个时刻，另一位主席，即该小组的资深成员，试图阻止这一切，说了一些类似“好了，这种愚蠢的行为够了。
Let's stop this right now. And he, the Israeli, said, I refuse to stop until I receive an apology. I want a public apology. And the Dutch ambassador said, what are you talking about? I didn't do anything that requires an apology. I refused to apologize. And so they went back and forth sort of like that
我们现在就停止吧。”而那位以色列人说：“除非我得到道歉，否则我拒绝停止。我要公开道歉。”那位荷兰大使说：“你在说什么？我没做任何需要道歉的事。我拒绝道歉。”于是他们就这样来回争执
for a little bit until the Israeli demanded an apology and said if he didn't get it, he would leave. And at that point, he started to kind of pack up his belongings and put his things in his briefcase and backpack and was preparing to leave. And if I understand correctly, what the Israeli negotiator was sort of upset about was the implication that because he was Israeli,
了一会儿，直到那位以色列人要求道歉，并说如果得不到道歉，他就会离开。就在那时，他开始收拾自己的物品，把东西放进公文包和背包里，准备离开。如果我理解得没错，那位以色列谈判代表感到不安的是，这种暗示：因为他是以色列人，
you know, there would be special scrutiny that was attached to his work or to the work of the journal, that it would be seen with skepticism that he was biased in some way. He saw himself as being an objective scholar and whose work should be treated objectively and the fact that he was Israeli was beside the point. The Dutch ambassador was saying, let's pay attention to the reality on the ground. This is a heated conflict. You're Israeli.
他的工作或期刊的工作会受到特别的审查，会被怀疑他以某种方式存在偏见。他认为自己是一位客观的学者，他的工作应该得到客观对待，而他是以色列人这一事实与此无关。那位荷兰大使则是在说，让我们关注实地的现实。这是一场激烈的冲突。你是以色列人。
We're talking about the Israeli-Palestinian conflict, this is gonna get more scrutiny. And I can see from both people's points of view how they came to their positions, but I can also see how both people felt personally attacked in the situation. Exactly, yeah, exactly what happened. And then other people tried to sort of say,
我们正在谈论以巴冲突，这必然会受到更多的审查。我能从两个人的角度理解他们为何坚持自己的立场，但我也能看出他们两人在当时的情况下都感到受到了人身攻击。没错，是的，事情就是这样发生的。然后其他人试图说，
hey, you know, we're here to, you know, do good things for the world. And we're really here to try to understand and help the world, you know, with the peace process. And let's remember that. And let's try to put this conversation in that context. And so there were multiple attempts. It was very interesting to kind of watch this because again, it's a room full of very skilled people, but who were thrown into this by surprise and unprepared. And so at some point, the Israeli packed up and left, and the Dutch ambassador packed up and left, and the irony was that an hour or so before there was this paper on the role of identity and conflict and here both of these individuals I think felt their identities, either their national identities and or their professional identities attacked publicly. And it really disabled them their capacities to do what they would usually do, which is sort of manage
“嘿，你知道，我们在这里是为了给世界做些好事。我们真的是为了尝试理解并帮助世界解决和平进程问题。让我们记住这一点。让我们试着把这次谈话放在那个背景下。”所以有过多次尝试。观察这一切非常有趣，因为同样，这是一个满屋子都是非常有能力的人，但他们被突如其来的情况弄得措手不及。所以到最后，以色列人收拾东西离开了，荷兰大使也收拾东西离开了。讽刺的是，就在一小时前，还有一篇关于身份在冲突中作用的论文，而在这里，我认为这两个人都觉得他们的身份，无论是民族身份还是职业身份，都受到了公开的攻击。这确实使他们失去了通常会做的事情的能力，也就是管理
the situation if other people were in that. But they were facing it personally. Something similar happened to Peter in his own apartment building in Manhattan. It involved a neighbor whom he calls David. I've known him probably for 10, 12 years, something like that.
这种局面。但他们当时正身处其中。彼得在曼哈顿自己的公寓楼里也发生了类似的事情。这涉及一位他称之为大卫的邻居。我认识他大概有10到12年了，差不多是这样。
You know, at times I'm on the elevator when he gets on. And what I noticed is that on occasion, he started to make comments about Me Too marches or Black Lives Matter marches or things that were happening in the streets of the city, kind of sarcastic remarks about those things or climate change. And then at some point, it became clear to me that he was a strong supporter of Donald Trump. This had come just in a conversation in front of the building.
你知道，有时他上电梯时我正好也在。我注意到，偶尔他会开始对“我也是”（Me Too）游行、“黑人的命也是命”（Black Lives Matter）游行或城市街头发生的事情发表评论，对这些事情或气候变化发表一些讽刺性的言论。后来，我清楚地意识到他是唐纳德·特朗普的坚定支持者。这只是在楼前的一次谈话中显露出来的。
And then some of the things he started to say to me seemed rather extreme at some point. He mentioned something about having a lot of respect for Vladimir Putin, thinking he was a good leader. At some point, I just started to think, okay, I can't get into a back and forth conversation with him that's going to be constructive. I'm just out. I basically just pulled away, stopped engaging. If I'd see him, I'd smile, but I'd just move on. I really just tried to unplug from the relationship.
然后他开始对我说的某些话在某种程度上显得相当极端。他提到对弗拉基米尔·普京非常尊重，认为他是一位好领导人。在某个时刻，我只是开始想，好吧，我无法与他进行一场建设性的来回对话。我退出。我基本上只是退缩了，停止了互动。如果我见到他，我会微笑，但会直接走开。我真的只是试图切断与这段关系的联系。
And was this because you were neighbors and you just didn't feel like this was the kind of conversation you wanted to have with the neighbor, or was this also that your own politics and preferences were not aligned with his? I think it's a combination of both. I think I didn't feel like he was someone that I could try to reason with because he would just sort of hold court, hold forth in his opinions to me were just informed very differently from mine. So I didn't see where we could go with this,
这是因为你们是邻居，你只是觉得这不像是你想和邻居进行的谈话，还是因为你自己的政治立场和偏好与他不一致？我认为两者兼而有之。我觉得他不是一个我可以尝试说理的人，因为他只会高谈阔论，而他的观点在我看来与我的观点有着截然不同的依据。所以我看不出我们能谈出什么结果，
which is why I felt like, yeah, I think I just need to disengage. So there is some element of irony here, Peter, which is that you are someone who studies conflict and you are someone who studies disagreement, but your response to this person who disagreed with you was, I anticipate there's going to be conflict and my solution to this is to disengage to this person who disagreed with you was, I anticipate there's going to be conflict and my solution to this is to disengage with this person and try not to bump
这就是为什么我觉得，是的，我想我只需要脱离这种关系。所以这里面有一些讽刺的成分，彼得，那就是你是一个研究冲突和分歧的人，但你对这个与你意见不合的人的反应是，我预见到会有冲突，而我的解决方案是脱离与这个人的关系，并尽量不再碰到他。
into him again. Fair. That's fair. And again, I think what most of us in this field of conflict resolution peace building, it's an eclectic field, but most of us will say that when it happens to us, when we're in the middle of it and our passions get triggered or our politics get triggered, it's a different kind of problem. It's somewhat what happened in Hamburg at this meeting of my colleagues on the Middle East.
公平。这很公平。再说一次，我认为我们这个冲突解决和和平建设领域的大多数人，这是一个折衷的领域，但我们大多数人会说，当它发生在我们自己身上时，当我们身处其中，我们的激情被触发或我们的政治立场被触动时，这是另一种问题。这有点像在汉堡那次关于中东问题的同事会议上发生的事情。
So, yeah, I think it's not something I'm proud of, but I think my cost-benefit assessment at the time was, look, this isn't going anywhere. I don't see him being open to listening or talking to me, and I don't have the energy for this, so I'm out. From international forums to neighbors in an apartment building, stray comments often lead to bigger problems. Once conflicts are up, it can be difficult to put the genie back into the bottle. When we come back, understanding the roots of the invisible forces that drive us apart. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan.
所以，是的，我认为这不是我引以为豪的事情，但我认为我当时的成本效益评估是，看，这不会有任何结果。我不觉得他愿意倾听或与我交谈，我也没有精力处理这个，所以我退出了。从国际论坛到公寓楼里的邻居，随意的评论往往会导致更大的问题。一旦冲突升级，就很难再把精灵放回瓶子里。稍后回来，我们将了解驱动我们分裂的无形力量的根源。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. We all have moments in our lives when we have to take something we've learned and put it into practice in the real world. Doing so, of course, is often a lot harder than we think it'll be. At Columbia University, social psychologist Peter Coleman got to witness the gap between theory and practice first hand. On October 7th, 2023, the Palestinian militant group Hamas launched a surprise attack on southern Israel. It killed and wounded thousands of Israelis. The incident launched a bloody reprisal with tens of thousands of Palestinians killed by Israeli bombs and a ground invasion of Gaza.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。我们一生中都有必须将所学知识付诸实践的时刻。当然，这样做往往比我们想象的要困难得多。在哥伦比亚大学，社会心理学家彼得·科尔曼亲眼目睹了理论与实践之间的鸿沟。2023年10月7日，巴勒斯坦激进组织哈马斯对以色列南部发动了突然袭击。它造成数千名以色列人伤亡。这一事件引发了血腥的报复，数万名巴勒斯坦人在以色列的轰炸和地面入侵加沙中丧生。
Peter, not long after the war in Gaza got underway, you were preparing to teach a class at Columbia University. Paint a picture for me of what happened that Wednesday evening? Sure. for me of what happened that Wednesday evening? Sure, yeah. So conditions at Columbia escalated fairly rapidly after the October 7th incursion. And we sort of felt it right away. There were almost immediate protests. And several of my students come from different parts of the university, a big group of them were coming from the School of International Public Affairs.
彼得，在加沙战争开始后不久，你正准备在哥伦比亚大学上一堂课。请为我描述一下那个周三晚上发生了什么？当然。是的。所以，在10月7日的入侵之后，哥伦比亚大学的情况升级得相当快。我们几乎立刻就感受到了。几乎立即就出现了抗议活动。我的几名学生来自大学的不同部门，其中一大群人来自国际公共事务学院。
And they're often international students that are studying diplomacy and international affairs. And this group were coming into my class just before 5 p.m. at the evening and were looking shaken and they were looking at me with a concern, and so they came right up to me and started to describe their experience of the day, which is that they were in classes in the School of International Public Affairs, and some of their peers
他们通常是学习外交和国际事务的国际学生。这群人在晚上5点前赶到我的课堂，看起来很震惊，他们带着担忧看着我，所以他们直接走到我面前，开始描述他们当天的经历，那就是他们在国际公共事务学院上课时，他们的一些同学
in a classroom had stood up and pointed to other students and called them out and said, they're supporters of Hamas or they're refusing to allow, you know, our point of view to be expressed. And so they would name names and pointed each other in a classroom, which was again, not typical protocol in classrooms in Columbia. And so they were verbally attacking or accusing one another. And they left that class to come walk, you know, two blocks to my building.
在教室里站起来，指着其他学生并公开点名，说他们是哈马斯的拥护者，或者他们拒绝让我们的观点得到表达。所以他们会在教室里指名道姓地指责对方，这在哥伦比亚大学的课堂上并不是典型的礼仪。于是他们互相进行言语攻击或指责。他们离开那间教室，步行两个街区来到我的大楼。
And in front of my building, there was parked a truck. And it was a large truck that had four screens on the side of the back of the truck that were television screens. And this truck had been driving around the outskirts of campus and was showing either hostages that had been taken, Israeli hostages that had been taken by Hamas, images of these individuals, and images of students with their names and contact information that they say were not supporting
而在我的大楼前，停着一辆卡车。那是一辆大卡车，车厢后部侧面有四个屏幕，那是电视屏幕。这辆卡车一直在校园外围行驶，展示着被哈马斯劫持的人质，这些人的图像，以及那些他们声称不支持以色列或支持哈马斯的学生的图像和他们的姓名及联系方式。
Israel or were supporting Hamas. Other incidents like this were popping up all over the campus. Eventually, police showed up. And I was teaching on the first floor the sirens were going by. I could see different clusters of squad cars driving past us. So the atmosphere was very tense in our room on campus. And they had just spent the day navigating this and came into my classroom. And they were triggered and traumatized by this. And one of them said to me, I don't know if I should stay here. I didn't expect this to happen in New York, and I don't know if
校园里到处都在出现类似的其他事件。最终，警察出现了。我当时在一楼上课，警笛声不断经过。我可以看到不同的警车群从我们身边驶过。所以我们校园房间里的气氛非常紧张。他们刚刚度过了处理这一切的一天，然后走进了我的教室。他们被这些事情触动并受到了创伤。其中一个人对我说：“我不知道我是否应该留在这里。我没想到在纽约会发生这种事，我甚至不知道
I should even stay here. So that was my experience of the first encounter with how this was playing out on campus in my class. So over the years, Peter, you have studied conflicts that you call intractable conflicts. Can you tell me what you mean by the term? There's obviously the colloquial understanding of an intractable conflict, a conflict that seems to drag on endlessly. But you're using it, I think, in a more specific way. Tell me what you mean by intractable conflicts.
我是否应该留在这里。”这就是我第一次亲身经历这种情况在校园和我的课堂上是如何演变的。所以多年来，彼得，你研究了你所称的“棘手冲突”。你能告诉我你所指的这个术语是什么意思吗？显然，人们对“棘手冲突”有一种通俗的理解，即一种似乎无休止地拖延下去的冲突。但我想你是在用一种更具体的方式使用它。告诉我你所指的“棘手冲突”是什么意思。
Well, scholars that study these things, these long-term difficult demanding conflicts, really see there are three qualities that distinguish them from other kinds of more manageable conflicts. One is that they tend to be highly destructive. The intensity or the level of destructiveness can escalate and de-escalate, but the pattern is very destructive. They tend to endure for long periods of time. We call them also protracted conflicts that can go on for some four decades, if not more. And most importantly, in terms of diagnosing them or understanding them as intractable, is they have a history often where there have been many good faith attempts to address them and to work them out.
嗯，研究这些长期、困难、高要求冲突的学者们，确实认为有三个特质将它们与其他更容易管理的冲突区分开来。第一，它们往往具有高度破坏性。强度或破坏程度可能会升级或降级，但模式是非常破坏性的。它们往往持续很长时间。我们也称它们为“旷日持久的冲突”，可以持续四十年甚至更久。最重要的是，在诊断它们或将它们理解为棘手冲突时，它们通常有一段历史，即有过许多善意的尝试来解决和处理它们。
And they may be mediations, they may be formal, they may be informal or negotiation processes. But they have a history of attempts to end them that either seem to have no effect or actually backfire. And so, yes, they have that kind of quality where they bring things in. I have to say it's, you know, they sometimes feel like like a storm, like a like a hurricane that gathers and has that kind of force that's bigger than us. Just step away from what's happening in the Middle East for a second to look at another conflict that I think many Americans are seeing. Many people feel like the partisan divide in our country is getting deeper and it feels like an intractable conflict. Now thankfully for the most part I don't think it devolves
它们可能是调解，可能是正式的，可能是非正式的，或者是谈判进程。但它们有一段试图结束它们的历史，这些尝试要么似乎毫无效果，要么实际上适得其反。所以，是的，它们确实有那种把事情卷入其中的特质。我必须说，它们有时感觉就像一场风暴，像一场聚集并具有那种比我们自身更强大的力量的飓风。让我们暂时离开中东正在发生的事情，看看我认为许多美国人正在看到的另一种冲突。许多人觉得我们国家的党派分歧正在加深，感觉就像一场棘手冲突。现在值得庆幸的是，在很大程度上，我不认为它会演变成
into violence, at least at the level of violence that you see in geopolitical conflicts and war. But there have been times in the United States, in the history of the United States, where conflict between Americans has resulted in war. Can you talk about where the partisanship qualifies as the kind of intractable conflict that you're talking about? And in fact, has it gotten worse? Is it an example of intractable conflict? I do think it is an example of intractable conflict? I do think it is an example, and it is how I think about political polarization in the
暴力，至少没有达到你在地缘政治冲突和战争中看到的那种暴力程度。但在美国历史上，美国人之间的冲突确实曾导致战争。你能谈谈党派之争在什么程度上符合你所说的这种棘手冲突吗？事实上，它变得更糟了吗？它是棘手冲突的一个例子吗？我确实认为它是一个例子，这就是我目前看待美国政治极化的方式。同样，它并不总是这样，但今天确实如此。根据一些衡量标准，这大约是60年来红蓝美国人之间敌意和距离不断增加的轨迹，例如在国会中，更多共和党或保守派，更多民主党或进步派的个人群体。我们已经看到了缺乏两党合作
US right now. Again, it's not always been this way, but it is this way today. By some measures, this is something like 60-year trajectory of increasing enmity and distance between red and blue Americans, more Republican or conservative, more Democrat or progressive groups of individuals, for example, in Congress. We've seen a lack of bipartisanship
以及国会中阻挠主义的增加。这种情况实际上自1970年代末以来一直在持续。所以按照这个标准，在政治上，
and an increase in obstructionism in Congress. And that's continued really since the late 1970s. So by that measure, politically, That's continued really since the late 1970s. By that measure, politically, we see that this division and inability to work together to cross the aisle. It's also true in attitudes. Pew Research Trust measures attitudes of voters and Americans, mainstream bottom-up. They've been tracking similar kinds of affective trends.
我们看到这种分裂和无法跨越党派界限共同工作的能力。在态度上也是如此。皮尤研究中心衡量选民和美国人的态度，主流自下而上的态度。他们一直在追踪类似的这种情感趋势。
You know, a lack of warmth or even a sort of cold feeling towards the other side that has been growing also since the late 1970s. So it's something that we see emotionally and then politically, ideological differences on issues. And we have seen an increase in some political violence that's taken place over the last certainly 20 years. There's a book called How Civil War Starts, and it's written by a woman named Barbara Walter. She by the way, works as an analyst for the CIA and looks at political stability around the world. And so they have metrics where they sort of track
你知道，对另一方缺乏温暖，甚至有一种冷漠的感觉，这种感觉自1970年代末以来也在增长。所以这是我们在情感上看到的，然后在政治上，在议题上存在意识形态差异。而且我们确实看到过去20年里发生了一些政治暴力事件的增加。有一本书叫《内战是如何开始的》，作者是一位名叫芭芭拉·沃尔特的女性。顺便说一下，她在中央情报局担任分析师，研究世界各地的政治稳定性。所以他们有衡量标准，他们会追踪
the data. And her position is that when we think about our first civil war, what we think about is armies in a field with muskets and uniforms. And her position is that that's not how political violence will take place here. That one of the things we're seeing here in the US is an increase in small militant groups who mobilize and do whatever they can to destabilize the status quo. And so we're not seeing the violence, obviously,
数据。她的立场是，当我们想到我们的第一次内战时，我们想到的是战场上拿着火枪、穿着制服的军队。而她的立场是，政治暴力在这里不会以那种方式发生。我们在这里看到的现象之一是小型激进团体的增加，他们动员起来，尽其所能破坏现状。所以我们显然没有看到
that we see in Gaza today, but we are seeing our own versions of escalation of political violence, which are highly concerning. Peter and his colleagues have studied how conflicts escalate. Some of it has to do with individual psychology, our inclination to lose our temper as during a conflict, or to seek out sources of news that match our pre-existing beliefs. These forces are amplified by group psychology,
我们在今天的加沙看到的暴力，但我们确实看到了我们自己版本的政治暴力升级，这非常令人担忧。彼得和他的同事研究了冲突是如何升级的。其中一些与个人心理有关，即我们在冲突中失去理智或寻找符合我们既有信仰的新闻来源的倾向。这些力量被群体心理所放大，
our tendency to herd together and defend the pack. At a societal level, the organization and structure of political systems can exacerbate division by creating zero-sum winner-take-all dynamics. While we often focus on these causes one by one, misinformation, a populist leader, gerrymandering, Peter says the real challenge is that all the issues are intertwined. My whole point is that there is no one thing that drives this. It's not Trump, it's not gerrymandering, it's not the internet, it's not media, it's not you or your tribal tendencies or your group. It's how these things align and start to feed each other in ways
即我们聚在一起并保卫群体的倾向。在社会层面，政治体系的组织和结构可以通过创造零和的“赢家通吃”动态来加剧分裂。虽然我们经常一个接一个地关注这些原因，如错误信息、民粹主义领导人、选区划分不公，但彼得说，真正的挑战在于所有这些问题都是交织在一起的。我的全部观点是，没有单一因素驱动这一切。不是特朗普，不是选区划分，不是互联网，不是媒体，不是你或你的部落倾向或你的群体。而是这些事物如何对齐并开始以某种方式相互助长，
that start to take on a life of their own, and then it does feel bigger than us. And so even if you and I decide, all right, I've had it with political enmity, I'm not gonna listen to the outrage on television anymore, I'm gonna really just live my life. It's so hard to not be sucked into these patterns and triggered by events or things that our friends say or don't say,
从而开始拥有自己的生命，然后它确实感觉比我们自身更强大。所以即使你和我决定，好吧，我受够了政治敌意，我再也不会听电视上的愤怒言论了，我真的只想过我自己的生活。要不被卷入这些模式，不被事件或我们的朋友所说或未说的话所触动，是如此困难，
you know, because so much of our life and our society and our culture is contributing to these simple divides. The complexity of the forces that drive us apart explains why simple interventions to bring people together often don't work. Peter tells a story about a group called My Country Talks, where journalists bring political opponents together to chat or break bread. One such effort brought together a military veteran from Pennsylvania who was a die-hard supporter of Donald Trump with a voter who opposed Trump,
你知道，因为我们生活、社会和文化中的很大一部分都在助长这些简单的分歧。驱动我们分裂的力量的复杂性解释了为什么将人们聚集在一起的简单干预措施往往不起作用。彼得讲述了一个名为“我的国家对话”（My Country Talks）的组织的故事，记者们让政治对手聚在一起聊天或共进晚餐。其中一项努力将一名来自宾夕法尼亚州的退伍军人，他是唐纳德·特朗普的铁杆支持者，与一名反对特朗普的选民聚在了一起，
a yoga teacher from Brooklyn. So they met in New York City. They agreed to both come to New York City and they met for breakfast and they went for a walk in Central Park. And it went pretty well. You know, they had a good connection between them and, you know, they had things common that they found and, you know, mostly talking about their family and their work and what they did.
一位来自布鲁克林的瑜伽老师。所以他们在纽约市见面了。他们同意都来到纽约市，他们共进早餐，并在中央公园散步。进展得相当顺利。你知道，他们之间建立了良好的联系，而且，你知道，他们发现彼此有共同点，而且，你知道，主要是谈论他们的家庭、工作和他们所做的事情。
And so that went fairly well. And then they agreed to meet the next night, I guess, and go to a they went to a Brooklyn Nets basketball game. So they agreed to meet there and they went to the game. And then after the game, they went out for drinks. And that's when things went south. The journalist who'd brought the opponents together was feeling hopeful about the conversation.
所以进展得相当顺利。然后他们同意第二天晚上见面，我想，他们去了一场布鲁克林篮网队的篮球比赛。所以他们同意在那里见面，他们去了比赛。比赛结束后，他们出去喝了一杯。就在那时，事情变得糟糕了。那位将对手聚集在一起的记者对谈话感到充满希望。
He decided to bring up a controversial topic to see what would happen. He asked the two about their attitudes towards Colin Kaepernick, the former NFL quarterback who kneeled during the national anthem to protest racial inequality in the United States. At the time, President Donald Trump suggested Colin Kaepernick should be kicked out of his team. The journalists asked them, what did they think about that whole event?
他决定提出一个有争议的话题，看看会发生什么。他问两人对科林·卡佩尼克（Colin Kaepernick）的态度，这位前NFL四分卫在国歌期间下跪，以抗议美国的种族不平等。当时，唐纳德·特朗普总统建议科林·卡佩尼克应该被踢出他的球队。记者问他们，他们对整个事件有什么看法？
And immediately that erupted into a diatribe and the yoga teacher started to get very angry and enraged and the vets responded and there you know as he said the F-bombs started to fly and they really really became aggressive and terrifying and then one of them storm stormed out and the other stormed out. out. When I pushed this organization, My Country Talks, on this story, they said, yeah, this is happening probably more than we want. That under the current conditions, just bringing people together to chat, as well-intentioned as it is, oftentimes is insufficient or can backfire and can really go south.
立刻，这演变成了一场谩骂，瑜伽老师开始变得非常愤怒和狂暴，退伍军人也做出了回应，正如他所说，脏话开始飞舞，他们真的变得非常有攻击性和可怕，然后其中一个人冲了出去，另一个人也冲了出去。当我向“我的国家对话”这个组织追问这个故事时，他们说，是的，这种情况发生的频率可能比我们想要的还要多。在当前条件下，仅仅把人们聚在一起聊天，尽管出发点是好的，但往往是不够的，或者可能会适得其反，真的会变得很糟糕。
And there is, there's peer research, it's now probably out of 2018 or 2019 about how red and blue Americans feel when they speak across the divide. And the majority of us leave those conversations feeling more frustrated and more alienated from the other side than before because it's not as simple as just get together and talk. For its part, My Country Talks reports that hundreds of thousands of people have taken part in these conversations. The organization
而且，有皮尤研究中心的研究，现在可能是2018年或2019年的数据，关于红蓝美国人在跨越分歧交谈时的感受。我们大多数人在结束这些谈话时，感觉比以前更加沮丧，与另一方的疏离感更强，因为这并不像聚在一起谈谈那么简单。就其本身而言，“我的国家对话”报告称，成千上万的人参与了这些对话。该组织
says that of those who were surveyed afterward, 80% on average say they're happy with how the interaction went. The psychological principle behind my country talks and other programs like it was articulated by the social psychologist Gordon Alport many decades ago. He believed that direct contact between different social groups could promote mutual understanding, faster empathy, and reduce prejudice. But what Gordon Allport was very clear to identify in his research was, you know, there are certain conditions where that goes well and one of the conditions that's important is that, you know, that people are willing to do this and there's enough time that they spend together so that they actually can start to develop some kind of rapport or relationship
表示，在事后接受调查的人中，平均80%的人表示对互动过程感到满意。“我的国家对话”和其他类似项目背后的心理学原则是由社会心理学家戈登·奥尔波特（Gordon Allport）在几十年前阐述的。他认为，不同社会群体之间的直接接触可以促进相互理解，培养同理心，并减少偏见。但戈登·奥尔波特在他的研究中非常明确地指出，你知道，在某些条件下，这种情况会进展顺利，其中一个重要的条件是，你知道，人们愿意这样做，而且他们在一起花费足够的时间，以便他们实际上可以开始建立某种融洽关系或联系，
before they get to the conflict. And what a lot of organizations do, unfortunately, is start with a conflict. They say, you're on this side, you're on that side, let's go. And if they don't take the time to build up some sense of respect, rapport, trust, even in the facilitators, let alone each other, the other side, it can easily blow up under conditions like we have today. We all have people with whom we disagree. today. of intractable conflicts. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. We all have values and beliefs that we consider
在他们进入冲突之前。而不幸的是，许多组织所做的是从冲突开始。他们说，你在这一边，你在那一边，开始吧。如果他们不花时间建立某种尊重、融洽、信任，甚至在协调者之间，更不用说彼此之间，另一方，在像今天这样的条件下，它很容易就会爆发。我们都有与我们意见不合的人。棘手冲突的。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。我们都有我们认为
non-negotiable. Our convictions can run so deep that hearing someone argue against them can feel immoral. At Columbia University, social psychologist Peter Coleman studies the anatomy of conflict, why it happens, when it can lead to violence and war, and how we can build peace in our own lives and in the world at large. Peter, before you became a peace researcher, you worked at an inpatient hospital in New York City. What did you do there? I was what they call a mental health associate, which is basically as somebody that, you know,
不可妥协的价值观和信仰。我们的信念可以如此根深蒂固，以至于听到有人反对它们会让人觉得不道德。在哥伦比亚大学，社会心理学家彼得·科尔曼研究冲突的解剖学，为什么它会发生，何时会导致暴力和战争，以及我们如何能在自己的生活中和整个世界中建立和平。彼得，在你成为和平研究员之前，你在纽约市的一家住院医院工作。你在那里做什么？我当时是所谓的心理健康助理，这基本上就是一个人，你知道，
I was young and somebody that'll do anything you ask them to do. So we were counselors to some degree, but mostly we were just helping the nurses run the unit. At one point, a young man at the facility whom Peter had befriended locked himself in a room. He was breaking things and threatening violence. Staff members called the police for help. I knocked on the door and just said, look, you know, any chance that you can talk to me, you know, and immediately he said, go away, you know, you way. And I said, you know, look, there's a SWAT team coming. And you know how that's gonna play out.
我当时很年轻，是一个别人让你做什么你就做什么的人。所以我们在某种程度上是咨询师，但大多数时候我们只是在帮助护士管理病房。有一次，彼得在医院里结识的一名年轻人把自己锁在房间里。他在破坏东西并威胁要施暴。工作人员打电话给警察寻求帮助。我敲了敲门，只是说，看，你知道，你有机会和我谈谈吗，你知道，他立刻说，走开，你知道，你……我当时说，你知道，看，特警队要来了。你知道那会是什么结果。
And we could possibly avoid that. Is there any chance you would be willing to just talk to me? And so, you know, after a pause, he unlocked the door. And so I walked in and again, I wanna be honest, I wasn't really trained well to do this. I didn't really have kind of violence intervention techniques. I just was going on the basis that I knew this young man, he knew me, I felt like he trusted me, and that there was some chance that this could de-escalate. And I walked in the room and I closed the door behind me
我们可能可以避免这种情况。你愿意和我谈谈吗？所以，你知道，停顿了一下之后，他打开了门。于是我走了进去，再说一次，我想诚实地说，我并没有受过很好的训练来做这件事。我并没有那种暴力干预技术。我只是基于我认识这个年轻人，他认识我，我觉得他信任我，而且这有可能化解冲突。我走进房间，关上身后的门，
and I sat down immediately, which is one thing I knew to do is try to not be imposing, I'm tall, I didn't want us. So I just sat down and he was again, still enraged, very angry. He was pissed off that I had come in because you really wanted to punch somebody, you really wanted to hurt somebody, and he said to me, damn it, Peter,
我立刻坐了下来，这是我知道要做的唯一一件事，就是尽量不显得咄咄逼人，我个子很高，我不想……所以我只是坐了下来，他当时仍然很狂暴，非常愤怒。他很生气我进来了，因为他真的很想打人，他真的很想伤害某人，他对我说：“该死的，彼得，
why does it have to be you? I can't punch you. And eventually he was able to kind of talk his way down and de-escalate enough that he agreed to come out. And so we were able to send the SWAT team away in this particular incident. It didn't always work, but when there was some kind of relationship that we could try to leverage, sometimes it would allow us to bring the temperature down. Hmm. So your experiences at the hospital made you realize
为什么非得是你？我不能打你。”最终他能够通过谈话让自己冷静下来，并化解了足够的愤怒，以至于他同意出来。所以我们能够在那次特定事件中让特警队离开。这并不总是有效，但当我们可以尝试利用某种关系时，有时它会让我们降低冲突的温度。嗯。所以你在医院的经历让你意识到
that you had an interest in conflict resolution. And you were curious about what worked in de-escalating incidents. You came across a story that changed the way you thought about conflict. Tell me what happened in Boston in December 1994. Yeah, that's an extraordinary story. Boston was an epicenter of a lot of hostile rhetoric
你对冲突解决感兴趣。你很好奇什么方法能有效化解冲突事件。你偶然发现了一个改变了你对冲突看法的故事。告诉我1994年12月在波士顿发生了什么。是的，那是一个非凡的故事。波士顿是当时许多敌对言论和抗议活动的中心，
and protest around pro-life pro-choice. It's highly Catholic. It's something like 36% Catholic at the time. And in 1994, a man drove to two clinics in Brookline, Massachusetts with arms In 1994, a man drove to two clinics in Brookline, Massachusetts with arms and he pointed his rifle at one woman. She was pleading for her life and he said, you should pray the rosary and then shot her dead.
围绕着“反堕胎”与“支持堕胎”。那里天主教徒比例很高。当时大约有36%是天主教徒。1994年，一名男子带着武器开车前往马萨诸塞州布鲁克莱恩的两家诊所，他用步枪指着一名女子。她恳求他饶命，他说：“你应该祈祷玫瑰经”，然后开枪打死了她。
And so it was this horrible event that took place. Even today, if you mention this, people remember this story. It was a destabilizing time. The Archdiocese weighed in and they just said, this is unacceptable. The governor, the mayor, it really was, in the entire community and across the country probably was this very upsetting,
所以这是一个发生在当地的可怕事件。即使在今天，如果你提到这一点，人们仍然记得这个故事。那是一个不稳定的时期。大主教区介入了，他们只是说，这是不可接受的。州长、市长，这确实是，在整个社区乃至全国可能都是一件非常令人不安、
extraordinary thing. These leaders in the community call for peace. They ask people to come together to find common ground. But their pleas for peace and unity seemed hopeless. Despite the tragedy, people were more divided than ever in their beliefs. The incident had all the makings of an intractable conflict. But there was a group in town
非凡的事情。这些社区领袖呼吁和平。他们要求人们团结起来寻找共同点。但他们对和平与团结的恳求似乎毫无希望。尽管发生了悲剧，人们在信仰上比以往任何时候都更加分裂。这一事件具备了棘手冲突的所有要素。但镇上有一个组织
named the Public Conversations Project, and there was a woman that was the director of that, who had been doing work with pro-life and pro-choice activists in the community and had relationships across those differences. Her name was Laura Chason. And Laura reached out to Summer for Contacts and said, you know, would you be willing to have a conversation with somebody on the other side? And it wasn't an easy sell. People were afraid of violence.
名为“公共对话项目”，该项目的负责人是一位女性，她一直在社区中与反堕胎和支持堕胎的活动人士合作，并在这些分歧中建立了关系。她的名字叫劳拉·查森（Laura Chason）。劳拉联系了双方的联系人，说：“你知道，你愿意与另一方的人进行对话吗？”这并不容易推销。人们害怕暴力。
They were enraged by what happened and they were enraged at blaming the other side. And so it was a very difficult thing to do, but there was a handful of women. There were three pro-life leaders and three pro-choice leaders, all women, who agreed to temporarily meet and talk. And they agreed to just do this for one month.
他们对发生的事情感到愤怒，他们对指责另一方感到愤怒。所以这是一件非常困难的事情，但有一小群女性。有三位反堕胎领袖和三位支持堕胎领袖，都是女性，她们同意暂时见面并交谈。她们同意只这样做一个月。
One of the groups, the pro-life group, had met before the first meeting, they met at a friendlies and they had coffee. And they together prayed to God because they believed that they were about to sit down with murderers and that God would see that as a sin. And they prayed to God to pardon them for doing this. So they were really, you know, they really were fearful of one another and held each other in deep contempt.
其中一个小组，即反堕胎小组，在第一次会议之前见过面，她们在一家Friendly's餐厅喝了咖啡。她们一起向上帝祈祷，因为她们相信自己即将与杀人犯坐在一起，而上帝会认为这是一种罪。她们祈祷上帝宽恕她们这样做。所以她们真的，你知道，她们确实彼此恐惧，并对彼此怀有深深的蔑视。
And so to go into a room and have a conversation, even if it's well facilitated, ain't easy. They did it in secret. They didn't tell anybody in their families, in their lives, in their professions that they were doing this because of the potential consequences of it. They met in a church basement in Massachusetts.
所以走进一个房间进行对话，即使有很好的引导，也不容易。她们秘密地进行了这件事。她们没有告诉家人、生活中的人或职业中的人她们在做这件事，因为这可能带来的潜在后果。她们在马萨诸塞州的一间教堂地下室里见面。
But it went well enough that after a month they agreed to continue it for a bit and then they agreed to continue the conversation until the anniversary of the shooting. And what happened ultimately is that it took them five and a half years of facilitated conversations in this safe space and not telling members of their community what they were doing where they changed in terms of their feelings towards one another. They really came to, one of them described it as
但进展得还算顺利，一个月后他们同意继续进行一段时间，随后又同意将对话持续到枪击事件周年纪念日。最终发生的事情是，他们在这样一个安全空间里进行了五年半的引导式对话，并且没有告诉社区成员他们在做什么，期间他们对彼此的感受发生了改变。他们真的达到了某种程度，其中一人将其描述为
after a period of time we fell in love with each other because they came to really respect and appreciate the intelligence and the integrity and conscientiousness of each other and how they take up their work, really the importance of that. And so they became very close as a group. Importantly, this bridge building was less about the women changing their minds about abortion and more about finding areas adjacent to the central conflict where they agreed with one another as well as reasons to like one another.
一段时间后，我们爱上了彼此，因为他们开始真正尊重和欣赏对方的智慧、正直和尽责，以及他们对待工作的方式，这确实非常重要。因此，他们作为一个群体变得非常亲密。重要的是，这种架桥式的沟通与其说是为了让这些女性改变对堕胎的看法，不如说是为了在核心冲突之外找到彼此认同的领域，以及喜欢对方的理由。
And this is a really interesting and kind of paradoxical aspect of this is that they, you know, in dropping all the rhetoric and all the hate speech and all the go-to-automatics, you know, phrases that they would usually use, they really needed to speak honestly, carefully about why this issue was important to them. And as they came to really care for the other women across the divide, they really wanted them, you know, it really became important that they understood, that they joined them in their cause. And so it was in some ways a fraught dynamic, but because their relationships became, I would say, thicker, they became kinder and friendlier and more respectful, that they
这是一个非常有趣且带有某种悖论的方面，那就是，你知道，在抛弃了所有的修辞、所有的仇恨言论以及所有他们通常会使用的那些自动化的、你知道的短语之后，他们确实需要诚实、谨慎地谈论为什么这个问题对他们如此重要。随着他们开始真正关心跨越分歧的另一方女性，他们确实希望对方，你知道，理解她们并加入她们的事业变得非常重要。所以这在某种程度上是一种令人不安的动态，但因为他们的关系变得，我会说，更深厚了，他们变得更友善、更友好、更尊重彼此，以至于他们
ultimately came out publicly in 2001 in the Boston Globe. They authored an article called Talking with the Enemy where they detailed this experience. And then they held a press conference and they were amazed that at the press conference there were all kinds of media who were very, major networks were there and who were very interested in what they were doing.
最终在2001年公开出现在《波士顿环球报》上。他们撰写了一篇名为《与敌人交谈》的文章，详细描述了这段经历。随后他们举行了新闻发布会，令他们惊讶的是，发布会上出现了各种各样的媒体，非常重要的电视网也到场了，他们对这些女性所做的事情非常感兴趣。
And they believe that their decision to talk to each other, to get to know each other, and then ultimately find where they did have common ground, like the need to prevent unwanted pregnancies, the need to protect young women, and the need to really avoid violence, whatever they could do to keep violence from coming back to the community. They really felt that their activism had created the conditions where that was more likely to happen and they never wanted to see that again.
他们相信，他们决定相互交谈、相互了解，并最终找到共同点，比如预防意外怀孕的必要性、保护年轻女性的必要性，以及真正避免暴力的必要性，无论他们能做什么来防止暴力再次回到社区。他们确实感到，他们的行动主义创造了更有可能实现这一目标的条件，他们再也不想看到那种情况发生了。
So they came together in that way and they shared that message through media and through talks they gave at colleges and places around the country. And in some ways, they had a broad effect on the ethos around that particular division at that time. They really brought the temperature down. They modeled how to meet with the other side to get to know the other side, and they all changed their activism.
于是他们以这种方式走到了一起，并通过媒体以及在全国各地的大学和场所进行的演讲分享了这一信息。在某种程度上，他们对当时围绕这一特定分歧的社会风气产生了广泛的影响。他们确实降低了冲突的温度。他们为如何与对方会面以了解对方树立了榜样，他们也都改变了自己的行动方式。
You know, there are a couple of things that jump out at me. One is that I think we often imagine that if we could sit down with people who disagree with us, you know, in a couple of minutes we could quickly disabuse them of their wrong views and they will come around and see that we were right all along. And perhaps the women in this group believe that as well. They believe that if they could sit down with people on the other side, that in a matter of hours and certainly weeks or months, that the other side would come to see
你知道，有几件事让我印象深刻。第一，我认为我们经常想象，如果我们能与不同意我们的人坐下来谈谈，你知道，几分钟内我们就能迅速消除他们的错误观点，他们会回心转意，看到我们一直都是对的。也许这个小组里的女性也曾这样认为。她们相信，如果她们能与对方坐下来谈谈，那么在几个小时，当然是几周或几个月内，对方就会开始看到
that they were right. And they would change their minds. But really what happened was a process that was much more affective than cognitive, if you will. It wasn't so much I changed my views based on the arguments you placed before me, but that I come to see you not just as a fuller person in your humanity, but also come to like you. In some ways, it has a
她们是对的。他们会改变主意。但实际上发生的过程与其说是认知的，不如说是情感上的。与其说是我根据你摆在我面前的论点改变了我的观点，不如说是我开始不仅把你视为一个拥有完整人性的人，而且开始喜欢你。在某种程度上，这与
parallel with what happened in that inpatient facility that you were working at, which is, you know, the reason the guy didn't hit you was not because you convinced him that hitting you would be a bad idea. He actually liked you. And his own conflict is inner conflict of saying, I like Peter, but I want to hit Peter, you know, kept him from actually hitting you. Yeah. No, I think that's absolutely right. I mean, and I think you're right that initially, many of us agree to sit down and talk to the other people because we think if I can just get them to sit down and explain to them how crazy either that their logic is, you know, we can find a way out of this. But oftentimes that has very little positive effect, it is taking the time. And again, you know, and we talk about things long enough until we realize what we don't understand. And once
你工作的那家住院设施中发生的事情有相似之处，那就是，你知道，那个人没有打你并不是因为你说服了他打你是个坏主意。他实际上喜欢你。他内心的冲突，即“我喜欢彼得，但我想打彼得”，你知道，让他没有真的打你。是的。不，我认为这绝对正确。我的意思是，我认为你说得对，起初，我们许多人同意坐下来与对方交谈，是因为我们认为如果我能让他们坐下来，向他们解释他们的逻辑有多疯狂，你知道，我们就能找到出路。但通常这几乎没有什么积极效果，关键在于花时间。再说一次，你知道，我们谈论事情足够久，直到我们意识到我们不理解什么。一旦
you get there, then you start to think, oh, okay, well, then maybe there's something to learn here, right? And then it's not about persuading, it's really about listening and understanding. Mm-hm. The other thing that strikes me about the example you gave about these women in Boston is that they really approached their conversations almost like a bomb disposal squad, which is they didn't sort of wander in blightly and say, okay, there's a bunch of wires here. Let's figure out, maybe we should cut this one and let's see how it turns out. They actually sat down and very carefully took apart what they were doing.
你到了那一步，你就会开始想，哦，好吧，那也许这里有什么值得学习的东西，对吧？然后这就不再是关于说服，而是关于倾听和理解。嗯。关于你提到的这些波士顿女性的例子，另一件让我印象深刻的事情是，她们对待对话的方式几乎就像拆弹小组，也就是说，她们并没有盲目地走进去说，好吧，这里有一堆电线。让我们弄清楚，也许我们应该剪断这一根，看看结果如何。她们实际上坐下来，非常仔细地拆解了她们正在做的事情。
They took their time. They weren't in the public eye. They were doing this in private. And I think when it comes to conflict resolution, a lot of us imagine that we can just simply show up with a pair of clippers and sort of clip a wire to disarm a bomb and that's going to be it. We are underestimating how complex
她们花时间慢慢来。她们不在公众视野中。她们是在私下里做这件事。我认为在冲突解决方面，我们许多人想象我们可以简单地带着一把剪线钳出现，剪断一根电线来拆除炸弹，事情就解决了。我们低估了挑战的复杂性
and how difficult the challenge actually is. I think that's true sometimes. And I guess, what I want to say is conflict is in our life constantly, right? We have internal conflicts of our decision constantly. We have internal conflicts of decision processes. We have conflicts with our roommates and our spouses and our kids and our family. We're always negotiating and bumping into differences and disputes and preferences. We learn to manage them most of the time pretty constructively and either ignore them or to
以及挑战的难度。我认为有时确实如此。我想说的是，冲突不断地存在于我们的生活中，对吧？我们不断地有关于决策的内部冲突。我们有决策过程的内部冲突。我们与室友、配偶、孩子和家人有冲突。我们总是在协商，在差异、纠纷和偏好中磕磕碰碰。我们学会了在大多数时候相当建设性地管理它们，要么忽视它们，要么
talk through them. Some conflicts don't allow that. Some conflicts become too aligned with passion, with identity, with ideology, with history, and we just make the mistake of not understanding the distinction between, you know, maybe what we should call disputes and what we call deep conflicts. These political conflicts that we're talking about, you know, over abortion, over Trump, these are these are deep identity conflicts. They're based on, you know, a lot of assumptions and, you know, a deep affect and those are not easily discarded or worked through or fixed. I want to talk about another idea you have about conflict resolution and that's to take
通过谈话解决它们。有些冲突不允许这样做。有些冲突与激情、身份、意识形态和历史结合得太紧密了，我们只是犯了一个错误，没有理解我们应该称之为纠纷的东西与我们称之为深层冲突的东西之间的区别。我们正在谈论的这些政治冲突，你知道，关于堕胎，关于特朗普，这些是深层的身份冲突。它们基于，你知道，许多假设和，你知道，深层的情感，这些不是轻易就能抛弃、解决或修复的。我想谈谈你关于冲突解决的另一个想法，那就是利用
advantage of new beginnings. Tell me about the bombshell effect, Peter. Right. So the bombshell effect is, again, sort of exemplified by what happened in Brookline with the women. When this violence took place, it was so destabilizing. It was so shocking that these activists who had spent decades
新的开始。告诉我关于“重磅炸弹效应”，彼得。好的。所以“重磅炸弹效应”再次被布鲁克莱恩那些女性身上发生的事情所体现。当这种暴力发生时，它是如此具有破坏性。它是如此令人震惊，以至于这些几十年来一直
competing and obstructing each other were willing to sort of stop and think, okay, this can't happen again. We need to try something else. And so when sometimes there are extraordinary things that happen, COVID, health crises, you lose your job, you lose a loved one. When there are these destabilizing times, sometimes they provide a sense of instability that can make people more open to certain kinds of processes. So when we talk about the bombshell effect, we talk about a new start, a reset, and how sometimes under those conditions, choosing to reset, that can happen in the wake of extraordinarily difficult events. Peter also recommends that opponents talk to each other while going for a walk.
相互竞争和阻碍的活动家们愿意停下来思考，好吧，这种情况不能再发生了。我们需要尝试别的方法。因此，当有时发生非同寻常的事情时，比如新冠疫情、健康危机、你失业了、你失去了亲人。当这些动荡时期出现时，它们有时会提供一种不稳定性，使人们对某些类型的过程更加开放。所以当我们谈论“重磅炸弹效应”时，我们谈论的是一个新的开始、一次重置，以及在这些条件下，选择重置有时如何在极其困难的事件之后发生。彼得还建议对手在散步时进行交谈。
Physical movement, especially in beautiful surroundings, can sometimes spring people out of their habitual perspectives. Peter recently had a chance to put his ideas into practice. He reached out to his neighbor David and asked to go on a walk with him. I did it because I felt ashamed, because in 2021, I had spent two years prior to that writing a book called The Way Out, which was about overcoming, toxic polarization. And I wrote about ways to help with it.
身体运动，尤其是在优美的环境中，有时能让人们跳出他们习惯性的视角。彼得最近有机会将他的想法付诸实践。他联系了他的邻居大卫，并邀请他一起散步。我这样做是因为我感到羞愧，因为在2021年，我在此之前花了两年时间写了一本书叫《出路》，是关于克服有毒的极化。我写了一些有助于解决这个问题的方法。
And one of them was a chapter on movement. And about a year after I wrote the book, I was sitting and thinking about what I was proposing to other people and thought, you know, I can't just sit here with this estranged relationship with this, you know, kind enough man, I have to try to walk my own talk. So I emailed him out of the blue and I said, you know,
其中之一是关于运动的章节。在我写完那本书大约一年后，我坐下来思考我向别人提议的内容，心想，你知道，我不能就这样坐在这里，与这个，你知道，足够善良的人保持这种疏远的关系，我必须尝试言行一致。所以我突然给他发了封邮件，我说，你知道，
would you be willing to take a walk with me in the park? And he wrote back right away and he said, you know, I'd be happy to take a walk with me in the park? And he brought back right away and he said, you know, I'd be happy to, you know, sit down and talk with you, but why walk? Are you CIA? Are you worried about surveillance? You know, he was very concerned about that whole notion. And I said, you know, no, just try to trust me in this.
你愿意和我一起在公园散步吗？他立刻回信说，你知道，我很乐意和你一起在公园散步？他立刻回信说，你知道，我很乐意，你知道，坐下来和你谈谈，但为什么要散步？你是中情局的吗？你担心被监视吗？你知道，他非常担心那个概念。我说，你知道，不，只是试着信任我。
So there's a reason, I have, you know, a rationale here, to trust me in this. So there's a reason, you know, Rationale here, I'll explain it to you. So he agreed and we agreed to meet and go for a walk in the park. You know, we live on the west side of Manhattan. We went into Riverside Park. I have to say, before I met with him, I was sick to my stomach.
所以有一个原因，我，你知道，这里有一个基本原理，试着信任我。所以有一个原因，你知道，这里的基本原理，我会向你解释。所以他同意了，我们约定见面去公园散步。你知道，我们住在曼哈顿西区。我们去了河滨公园。我必须说，在见到他之前，我感到非常紧张。
He too was clearly very anxious right away. He said to me, you know, yeah, happy to take a little walk with you. My wife isn't feeling well, so I may have to come back early. So, you know, he was, I was said, that's fine. No worries. No worries. And we walked. What I tried to do was follow my own recommendations, which means that I had to first of all, ask myself, like, what do I want to do here? What's the objective of this? Because we could have easily gotten triggered and gotten into political nonsense and gone
他显然也非常焦虑。他立刻对我说，你知道，是的，很高兴和你一起散步。我妻子身体不太舒服，所以我可能得早点回来。所以，你知道，他这样说，我说，没关系。别担心。别担心。我们散步了。我试图做的是遵循我自己的建议，这意味着我必须首先问自己，我在这里想做什么？这的目标是什么？因为我们很容易被触发，陷入政治废话，然后
nowhere. And so I really said to myself, you know, I reset and said, this is an opportunity to talk to somebody who's all in on Donald Trump and MAGA. And so take an opportunity to listen and try to get a sense of what that is. So I was very intentional about that. And then I was very intentional about how I approached the conversation. I didn't, we didn't jump right into Trump politics. At first Peter asked David about his life.
一事无成。所以我真的对自己说，你知道，我重置了一下，说，这是一个与一个完全支持唐纳德·特朗普和“让美国再次伟大”（MAGA）的人交谈的机会。所以要抓住机会倾听，试着了解那是什么。所以我对此非常有意识。然后我对我处理对话的方式非常有意识。我没有，我们没有直接跳进特朗普的政治话题。起初，彼得问了大卫关于他生活的情况。
They discovered they had some things in common. David was Jewish, Peter's wife was Jewish. But after they established some points of connection, the conversation got heavier. He started to talk about Trump and his ideas. So he was hitting a lot of conspiracy theories. But what I didn't do was what he expected me to do, which is to joust with him, to, you know, to parry and challenge.
他们发现他们有一些共同点。大卫是犹太人，彼得的妻子也是犹太人。但在他们建立了一些联系点之后，对话变得沉重起来。他开始谈论特朗普和他的想法。所以他提到了很多阴谋论。但我没有做他预料中我会做的事，那就是与他争论，你知道，去招架和挑战。
And I just listened. I asked some clarifying questions when he would say, oh, you know, we do this, we don't do that. I'd say, so your community is okay with this, but not that, not with that. And he'd say, yes, I'd say, okay. And so he was very passionate and driven and walked faster as we spoke and got very worked up. But at some point, what sort of happened is that we wrote a wave of that passion.
我只是倾听。当他说，哦，你知道，我们这样做，我们不那样做时，我会问一些澄清性的问题。我会说，所以你们社区对这个没问题，但对那个不行，是吗？他会说，是的，我会说，好的。所以他非常热情和执着，当我们交谈时走得更快，情绪变得非常激动。但在某个时刻，发生的事情是，我们驾驭了那种激情的浪潮。
And at some point as we were walking, because I wasn't challenging him, which is what he'd expected, he came to his own doubts. He started to say, all right, should I vote for this person again? Probably not, you know, or he made these mistakes and these mistakes.
在我们散步的某个时刻，因为我没有挑战他，而这正是他所预料的，他开始产生了自己的怀疑。他开始说，好吧，我应该再次投票给这个人吗？可能不会，你知道，或者他犯了这些错误和那些错误。
And so he started to come to his own, you know, contradictions or doubts about his position, which of course was much more powerful than anything I could have done. But we continued to walk and then at some point we were heading back towards the apartment and I said, well, you know, I know that your wife isn't feeling well.
所以他开始产生自己的，你知道，关于他立场的矛盾或怀疑，这当然比我能做的任何事情都要有力得多。但我们继续走，然后在某个时刻，我们正往公寓方向走，我说，嗯，你知道，我知道你妻子身体不太舒服。
And he said, oh, it's okay, we can walk a few more blocks. We continued and eventually ended back at the apartment. And when we got to the apartment, I had left a copy of my book in the front and handed it to him. And so look, you don't have to read this. I just wanted to give you some sense of why I asked. You know, he picked it up and he looked at the back
他说，哦，没关系，我们可以再走几个街区。我们继续走，最终回到了公寓。当我们到达公寓时，我把书放在前面，递给了他。我说，看，你不必读这个。我只是想让你了解我为什么提出邀请。你知道，他拿起书，看了看背面
and he said, yeah, political polarization. He said, that's a huge problem. I don't know what to do about it. He said, I feel like I spend all of my time just lost in the woods and angry, but I don't really know what to do about this thing. And I just said, well, I think what we just did is a start. About a week later, my son, who's 27, who has lived here for a long time, but this
他说，是的，政治极化。他说，这是一个巨大的问题。我不知道该怎么办。他说，我觉得我整天都迷失在森林里，很生气，但我真的不知道该怎么处理这件事。我只是说，嗯，我想我们刚才所做的就是一个开始。大约一周后，我27岁的儿子，他在这里住了很长时间，但这个
man had never communicated with, never had any contact with, or never looked at. He gets in the elevator with David, and David looks at him and said, oh, you're Peter's son. And my son Adelaide said, yes, yes. He was sort of taken back and surprised. And he said, all right, well, tell your father that I'm reading his book and it's not bad. And I thought that is the best endorsement
人从未与他交流过，从未有过任何接触，甚至从未看过他。他和大卫一起进了电梯，大卫看着他说，哦，你是彼得的儿子。我儿子阿德莱德说，是的，是的。他有点吃惊和意外。他说，好吧，告诉你父亲，我正在读他的书，还不赖。我想那是最好的背书
that I could imagine having for a book is, you know, to have someone who you think would be opposed to it, say it's not bad. And I do want to say that this happened, you know, to have someone who you think would be opposed to it say, it's not bad. And I do want to say that this happened, you know, a year and a half ago, and we continue conversations. So we've been connected. He sends me things to read. I send him things to read.
我能想象到的对一本书的评价是，你知道，让一个你认为会反对它的人说它不赖。我确实想说，这发生在，你知道，让一个你认为会反对它的人说它不赖。我确实想说，这发生在，你知道，一年半前，我们继续保持对话。所以我们一直有联系。他发给我一些东西读。我发给他一些东西读。
And occasionally we get together and talk and ideally walk, because that's when I feel like we connect the best. Peter Coleman is a psychologist at Columbia University. He's the author of The Way Out, How to Overcome Toxic Polarization. Peter, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, it's been a real pleasure. Thank you for having me on. Next week, we continue our us 2.0 series with a look at how the loudest voices shape and distort our understanding of political conflict. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy,
偶尔我们聚在一起交谈，理想情况下是散步，因为那是我觉得我们联系最紧密的时候。彼得·科尔曼是哥伦比亚大学的心理学家。他是《出路：如何克服有毒的极化》一书的作者。彼得，感谢你今天参加“隐藏的大脑”节目。哦，这真是我的荣幸。谢谢你邀请我。下周，我们将继续我们的“我们2.0”系列，看看最响亮的声音是如何塑造和扭曲我们对政治冲突的理解的。“隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑媒体”制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、
Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristin Wong, Laura Corell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. We end today's show with a story from our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. It's brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. In 2003, Jennifer Reinhardt suffered a traumatic fall that left her with life-threatening injuries. After three major surgeries and a medically induced coma, she was in tremendous pain. One night in the hospital still stands out in her memory.
安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行编辑。我们今天以我们姐妹播客“我未被歌颂的英雄”中的一个故事结束节目。它由T-Mobile商业版为您呈现。2003年，詹妮弗·莱因哈特经历了一次创伤性跌倒，导致她受了危及生命的伤害。在三次大手术和药物诱导昏迷后，她处于极度痛苦之中。医院里的一天晚上至今仍留在她的记忆中。
She was in a large amount of morphine to help her sleep through the pain. When she woke up, she was dripping with sweat and shivering. I was so cold, but shivering made my whole body hurt. And so I was also crying because it hurt so bad. And I was shivering and I couldn't stop. And I managed to also crying because it hurt so bad and I was shivering and I couldn't stop. And I managed to reach the call button and called for the nurse. And when the nurse came in and saw what was happening, she's like, oh honey, we'll get you out of this bed and we'll get you into clean sheets. And I just was panic struck
她服用了大量的吗啡来帮助她在疼痛中入睡。当她醒来时，她浑身是汗，颤抖着。我太冷了，但颤抖让我全身都疼。所以我也在哭，因为太疼了。我在颤抖，我无法停止。我设法也哭了起来，因为太疼了，我在颤抖，我无法停止。我设法按下了呼叫按钮，叫了护士。当护士进来看到发生了什么时，她说，哦，亲爱的，我们会让你离开这张床，我们会给你换上干净的床单。我当时惊慌失措
because every single piece of me hurt so badly. I didn't know that I would. I felt like I didn't know if I could even survive being moved out of the bed. And she called in an attendant and he was two or three times the size of me. And he walked over and scooped me up out of the bed like a little baby, so tenderly and so gently. He held me like I was made out of tissue paper. And he just held me very still and quiet and hummed a song very quietly while the nurses came in and quickly got the sheets changed.
因为我的每一寸身体都疼得厉害。我不知道我会怎样。我觉得我不知道自己是否能挺过被移出床的过程。她叫来了一名护理员，他比我大两三倍。他走过来，像抱婴儿一样温柔、轻柔地把我从床上抱起来。他抱着我，就像我是用薄纸做的一样。他只是非常安静、平稳地抱着我，并非常轻声地哼着一首歌，同时护士们进来迅速换好了床单。
There was something about the power of the sound of his voice and the vibration in his and how gently he was holding me, that just put a balm and a soothingness over that pain that I was feeling. When he set me back down in the bed and they changed my hospital gown and I was back in dry, warm, they brought warm blankets, it was really the first time since I had fallen that I felt sure that I was going to live through this. And then I'd get back home to my children.
他声音的力量、他怀里的震动以及他抱着我时那种温柔，给我的疼痛带来了一种慰藉和舒缓。当他把我放回床上，他们换了我的病号服，我又回到了干燥、温暖的环境中，他们拿来了暖和的毯子，那真的是我跌倒以来第一次感到确信自己能活下来。然后我能回到我的孩子们身边。
I wish he could have known just how much he helped me. was brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. You can find more of these stories on the MyAnsangHero podcast or at myansanghero.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我希望他能知道他给了我多大的帮助。由T-Mobile商业版为您呈现。您可以在“我未被歌颂的英雄”播客或myansanghero.org上找到更多此类故事。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。很快再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。